hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo la
salud and juliet riaño
[Música]
una reciente disputa geopolítica estaría
abriendo las puertas a miles de
inmigrantes hacia europa
belarús país fronterizo con la unión
europea sospechoso de dar paso libre y
asistir a personas en tránsito que
buscan llegar de manera irregular a
lituania un país que decidió levantar un
muro en la frontera común para contener
el éxodo los países del bloque europeo
creen que la masiva llegada de migrantes
responde a una forma de presión
orquestada por el presidente bielorruso
alexander lukachenko como represalia a
las sanciones impuestas en su contra por
la represión a opositores carolina los a
león nos lo cuenta en el siguiente
informe
la nueva puerta europa en los últimos
meses autoridades de lituania letonia y
polonia registraron un mayor número de
emigrantes cruzando sus fronteras desde
belarús su objetivo entrar en la unión
europea entre los migrantes un gran
número de iraquíes como en este
campamento virtual
grupo de turismo de femyts debía alguien
1400 dólares para que me lleve al bosque
creo que era la frontera me enseñaron el
camino y me dijeron ve por aquí entonces
camine
fue la migración irregular a lituania
registra en el 2021 más de 4000 personas
comparada a las 81 personas registradas
en todo el 2020 la unión europea acusa
al gobierno de belarús de ser
responsable por permitir el cruce
fronterizo en retaliación a las
sanciones impuestas tras la represión a
manifestantes en 2020
déjenme decir que esta provocación de
régimen de lukashenko es totalmente
inaceptable dejamos claro que no hay
acceso libre al territorio de la unión
europea r
lituania ordenó a sus patrulleros en la
frontera regresar a los migrantes a
belarús medida que fue desafiada por
ming
de tous spanish
ya hay cientos o incluso mil personas
bajo amenazas y los van a empujar al
territorio de belarús estas acciones
pueden generar un conflicto porque
nosotros no permitiremos violaciones de
fronteras nacionales
that's my friends
lituania aprobó la instalación de una
valla metálica de cuatro metros en 507
de los 670 kilómetros de frontera con
belarús otro obstáculo a los sueños de
miles de personas que buscan paz y
seguridad tomando riesgos al emprender
esta ruta
específicamente europa acusa a belarús
de facilitar el traslado de migrantes en
avión desde los países de medio oriente
hasta minsk y luego permitir el cruce
hacia lituania sin impedimentos de la
patrulla fronteriza bielorrusia y la
crisis interna en belarús que estalló
tras la reelección de lukashenko hace un
año ocasionó otro éxodo el de sus
ciudadanos hacia países vecinos en busca
de protección a opositores que fueron
reprimidos en las protestas antigobierno
de 2020 viven lejos de su país estas son
algunas de sus historias ha pasado un
año desde estas imágenes más de 35.000
personas fueron arrestadas y otras miles
golpeadas por la policía entre el verano
y otoño de 2020 en belarús 12 meses
después son miles los opositores en el
exilio
alexander y tatiana huyeron a polonia y
la vida que estoy viviendo ahora
pero todo lo que hice hace un año lo
volvería a hacer incluso habría hecho
más
bolsa lejos de casa ambos siguen
comprometidos con la lucha que dejaron
en belarús
nos traicionaríamos a nosotros mismos ya
nuestros pueblos y dejaremos de luchar
traicionaríamos a todos los que todavía
están en prisión
y es que alexander vivió las
consecuencias de una prisión en su país
donde fue brutalmente golpeado por la
policía
su madre lo recibió tras ser liberado
cada vez que veo vídeos de esos días ya
sean míos o de otras personas es difícil
ocultar el dolor que siento a veces
lloro cuando lo recuerdo es una parte de
mí una parte de mi vida que no
desaparecerá
juntos lograron formar una nueva vida
pero esperan algún día poder regresar
la velocista olímpica vilo rusa kristina
chimán usca ya también encontró refugio
en polonia
la atleta convertida en símbolo de la
oposición se negó a regresar a su país
tras los juegos de tokio por temor a
represalias en su contra luego de
criticar a las autoridades deportivas
bielorrusas buscó ayuda en el aeropuerto
de tokio y consiguió protección
espero que llegue el momento en que
belarús pueda ser libre y las personas
tengan la libertad de expresarse porque
estaba en muchos lugares de europa y
hablé con gente en japón y todos dicen
que tienen libertad de expresión en sus
países y su gente no teme ser escuchada
ni beratón esto ahora se siente segura
en polonia junto a su esposo y espera a
continuar su carrera deportiva sin
embargo teme por la seguridad de sus
padres que aún residen en belarús
mientras la lista de refugiados en el
mundo aumenta por cuenta de la represión
ejercida por el gobierno de alexandr
lukashenko son también miles los
migrantes que quedan en medio del
desafiante enfrentamiento contra europa
t quien es considerado el último
dictador del continente hasta que
inmigrantes de france 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]